let's jump to this next story and get
into the politics of of the day we have
this uh from timcast.com trump accused
of election meddling after endorsing
candidates in new york democratic
primary races
i'm sorry i love this man this is one of
the greatest trolls ever done
donald trump endorses lawyer dan goldman
who led the impeachment against him
saying lawyer dan goldman is running for
congress new york ten and it is my great
honor to strongly endorse him i do this
not because of the fact that he headed
up the impeachment committee and lost
but because he was honorable fair and
highly intelligent while it is well it
was my honor to beat him and beat him
badly
dan goldman has a wonderful future ahead
like i don't know how anyone sees that
anyone with any modicum of intelligence
and believes trump is literally
endorsing the guy when he's he's doing
like neg hits you know that is
it's like a backhanded compliment yeah
at these guys here's
he endorsed several other people but
here's the best part
you lean now who is a democrat so i i
looked her up she's a democrat assembly
member
running for new york 10
took the bait and said donald trump just
endorsed my multi-millionaire opponent
in case you need a reminder of what the
stakes are new york 10 choose your
fighter
she couldn't help it they can't help
themselves trump plays them like a
fiddle and now he's got them in fighting
over whether or not he actually supports
this guy this is what he has to do he
has the weight of the establishment
pushing against him right now and i've
been an advocate of like if someone's
coming at you and putting their full
force into you the best well one of the
best things you can do is move so that
you're not there anymore and that all
that pressure that donald trump is like
just goes into this nowhere land and end
up falling forward then you reappear and
then you're still back to you know who
you are the prophecy has been fulfilled
ladies and gentlemen from the babylon
bee ingenious move trump supports
impeachment forcing democrats to oppose
november 18th 2019 the beat does it
again wow the thing is his statement has
so much early 2016 energy to me like
there was a point in his presidency
where he really seemed to sort of get
lost i felt like maybe he didn't have uh
the correct support when he was already
in the white house but while he was
campaigning and you know throughout we
see we see it come go he really is just
this complete unpredictable force you
can't really tell what he's going to do
and he doesn't want to
uh
adhere to any traditional standards so
it's why it's so funny like
this is this is very much a like true
spark of trump to me as like when he
first announced that he was coming to
president it reminds me of all of the
debates he did his like booing of
hillary clinton on stage like he doesn't
he doesn't behave as they would like him
to i'm sure goldman is like what do i do
do i release a statement saying no thank
you
this is so much of what trump does is
what i've been talking about when i say
like throw a pie figuratively like
people in power need to just need to to
set a tone need to call out the bs need
to make a point trump does this all the
time
it's it's it's quite incredible but uh
yeah i have to wonder where we go in
this country
as this is the current level of politics
that we have i mean they they take the
bait donald trump trolls the democrats
what do you think i think too like there
is a level of like yesterday was looking
at this article it was eight of the ten
republicans who voted against trump are
out and
it's interesting because i think he's
trying to show the democrats that he has
influence within their party like not in
the way they're expecting he has more
influence in politics than anyone
predicts or is used to it's very unusual
to have a leader who can actually
bipartisanly reach across the aisles and
be like oh i it's not just the
republican primary side of influence i
can influence the democrats too he's not
even in office right now i love it can
you go back to the tweet the actual
tweet what i find odd about the original
the first one on the left yeah is
there's a dot dot
dot dot well it's because there's more
yeah what i just mean i just mean like
everything about
this there's four dots there's four dots
everything about like i just look at it
and i i see i see psychological
operations campaign it's like a psyop
right it's like exactly what you do when
you want to win hearts and minds and
if it's a real endorsement or if it's
not a real endorsement what what we
realize now is that uh everybody's
talking about it yep and that's what you
need when you're trying to campaign
early on we're three years out two and a
half two and some change out and we'll
start filling the effects of that like
tomorrow we're filling it today and so
this is only going to get more extreme
and more difficult but how much of this
is donald trump sitting down with a
group of like tacticians being like we
need to craft the perfect message or
it's him
lounging in a chair watching tucker
cross and being like anders is a guy and
he like grabs a thing of cheetos and
then i feel it's like both of those
i think he's good on a whim but i also
think like deliberately
uh people people forget he's a very
crafty business person and being in
business myself for a short period of
time i understand the tactics and even
tactics that i've brought across the
military aisle in planning and strategy
he is using all of these tactics to bear
and i think he's unpredictable he would
be unconventional or irregular in his
warfare approach while the rest of the
establishment
that you're draining that he's training
is very conventional i'm just thinking
about you know they call him a fascist
they claim he's like worse than hitler
could you imagine if donald trump like
ever did become a dictator and then
history is talking about how he rose to
power and it's like well he called
rozier dental fat pig and then he made a
tweet endorsing his opponents
it's just like wow
you know you know the history repeats
itself history rhymes but i think we're
getting something fresh with donald
trump to a certain degree i gotta ask is
this the 4d chess we were promised it's
kind of what it looks like to me yeah i
like to think when you hate if you hate
somebody that they are controlling you
if you have a mo so people that he's
done that he i mean he's taking control
of people's minds whether yeah whether
they like him or not well especially the
ones that hate
yeah that's a way that's a form of 4d
chess
i'm just reading the end of this like
winning against him made me realize so
just very talented i am amazing okay let
me read it let me read it so i read the
first part he goes on to say he will be
very compassionate and compromising to
those within the within the republican
party and will do everything possible to
make sure they have a fair chance at
winning against the radical left
democrats who he knows are destroying
our country i would like to thank dan
for fighting so hard for america and for
working so tirelessly to stop quote
trump unquote he was not easy to beat
but winning against him made me realize
just how very talented i am
most don't read the second one though
i'm so sorry this just like gets better
and better that's great i hope one
person said to him like i'll be
hilarious if you endorse the demo like
democrat and then he's like i'm done do
it right now he's like he's like sitting
in like his friend's basement they're
playing pool at the game on and they're
like dude dude you should endorse the
democrats like i'm totally gonna do it
it would make him freak out and they're
like he's like okay that's what i love
so he super chatted him i was like you
won't do it he was like oh yes i will
yeah i think maybe he has realized that
conventional tactics are not the way you
win against the liberal economic order
right now because they're just
conventionally using brute force you
know with the fbi raid on the house and
things like that so now he's taking an
unconventional i think approach
we saw we saw the democrats funding
republican messaging
and the idea was that it was going to
hurt trump to do this i think he was
like okay i'll play the game you're like
you want to play that game yeah you so
so think the democrats are like trump
endorsed these guys so let's prop them
up then in the general they'll lose so
trump says okay i'll endorse your guys
instead
and does
that's what i mean i think he they
underestimate how much influence he has
over everyone like we see it as like oh
it's just just those right people those
conservatives the maga base but it's
really not like trump is an institution
in and of himself and i think
you know he is sort of reviving the same
kind of disruptive energy that made him
stand out initially which made people
cover him when he was running in 2016
because they were like what is he doing
well he put his name in quotes too which
is nice because it shows that he's not
like he was against me he sees that he's
against the idea of what trump might be
yeah but someone said someone was steve
steve bannon's mullet responded to you
lynn
saying that's just weird why would he
endorse goldman and she said he said it
out loud to stop the left
i do not believe i'm sorry i can't
believe that this uh you lin woman i
proposing that right
actually believes it's a real
endorsement maybe she doesn't know like
do you think she seriously thinks he
maybe she's playing her own side but i
don't buy into it i think she literally
probably believes that it was an
endorsement i mean maybe she's betting
off headlines like enough people are
going to see trump endorses goldman
she's like they aren't going to look
into it i'm going to be able to yeah but
that would mean that she knows she's
lying to her potential constituents
she's possible
right is she is she lying for votes or
is she just really that dumb i'm going
with lying for votes for 500.
neither one seems like a good look you
know yeah my guess is ignorant that she
doesn't know that was the guy that tried
to impeach no he wrote that he headed
the impeachment committee it's in the
endorsement damn that i was wrong but
we're also i mean here here's the credit
to trump that's due that a lot of people
don't talk about this is a tactician
that killed isis like this dude like we
forget about isis and all the problems
that it was taking over the world we
were about to go to world war ten
he did that on his own accord as a
commander-in-chief and nobody talks
about like they ragged on him for it
they did they write him they said
austere scholar
how did he do it
well he i think he used i mean he used a
lot of different tactics but he used
special operations but it wasn't
advertised as a war so it wasn't
campaigning with media outlets that were
telling all the information it was a
closed compartmentalized operation that
was very deliberate using ranger
battalion using the best special special
mission units in the world
and crushed those guys and if it wasn't
for that i mean the things that we saw
on the tv when isis and their propaganda
was affecting the world
everybody was like in fear you saw
little kids running around with guns
killing innocent people from propaganda
videos from isis that was a thing like
we lived in that time and all of a
sudden we woke up one day like covet and
it didn't exist and it's because of
those tactics that he brought to bear so
i say that because he's a he's
deeply seated in strategy and
understanding tactics on all levels and
i think this is an easy psyops campaign
for him
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there